survival movies we've seen those can be
good now M night Shyamalan is gonna take
on that genre the guy has done good
movies before I wasn't imagining that
right he's done good movies in his life
after Earth so after Earth is set in the
future Will Smith is this really stoic
emotionless soldier and his son in real
life Jaden Smith plays his son in this
movie after that they crash land on this
planet full of predators little Smith's
legs have been broken he can't go out
there and help Jaden Smith because I
gotta you know go find the tail section
of the plane who knows there might be
survivors in the tail section of the
plane that allows for about one season
you need to get a beacon from it but
Jaden Smith's the only one who can go
Jaden Smith has that little omni-tool
from Mass Effect so Will Smith can talk
to him through there now we have our
adventure by adventure I mean slow
survival movie with Will Smith's kid in
it the premise of this movie is cool
enough there are predators out there you
know it's really dangerous wilderness
environment Jaden Smith has to survive
and if it had better direction and
better execution it would actually be
good as it stands though this movie was
boring the underlying tone of the movie
is the fact that Jaden Smith's character
and Will Smith's character are going to
bond his father and son because Will
Smith is really distant which makes him
very boring Will Smith brings all he can
to the table you can see a couple of
moments of conflict where he's like I'm
not supposed to be emotional but I am
all in although it's almost like M night
Shyamalan was like alright Will Smith
just imagine you being mace windu in the
prequels yeah he was kind of boring out
of touch these are the only two
characters we have basically in the
entire movie the fact that 50% of that
crew is boring and out of touch the fact
that the other half is uninteresting and
not really as good of an actor as the
guy playing the boring guy hole Smith's
son is not as good as him that's not
good either his name is Jaden Smith it
should be Jayden gonna get work no
matter what he's a legacy child
directors aren't gonna be like no I
don't want you in my movie but the fact
is he has a little bit of work to go
before I can be like oh he's a great
actor Jaden Smith needs a director who
can show him how to be all he can be a
director that can help him hone his
craft you know pairing Jaden Smith up
with the director of the happenings you
guys do the acting in there I don't need
to say more that's not good there's not
gonna help him out set him like three
steps back and night Shyamalan is no
stranger to slow movies generally
speaking you see his movies you're like
yeah they're all slow but his first
batch of movies we'll call them the ones
that were good slow as they may be they
were interesting stories interesting
star
raise good actors we had intrigue in
there we were like where is it going and
we know it's building to something now
we're watching a boring movie unfold
with actors who play boring people and
boring boredom and all that boring yes
some things don't make sense in the
movie either
no spoiler here but there's this one
scene where this predator clearly means
to kill Jaden Smith later on in this
movie that predator saves his life why I
have no idea I saw the movie and I just
don't know you'd almost argue that Jaden
Smith kind of helped it out but not
really predators don't see that way
they're not gonna be like oh hey thanks
for doing me a solid man oh yeah I'm an
animal I see you again I'm gonna be like
hey food there you are and now you're
dead did you see things like that is
convenient ways to get the characters
out of tough spots so one of the
premises in this movies Jaden Smith is
supposed to conquer his fear that's how
he's gonna grow as a character and he'll
become just like Will Smith someone who
has already conquered his fear but Will
Smith is an emotionless
so apparently this movie goes on the
premise that in order to conquer your
fear you're supposed to become an
emotionless so we're rooting for
this kid to become an emotionless
like his emotionless
father
yeah we're also supposed to care about
their father-son bonding experience
something that emotionless
aren't supposed to care about so why
should we have conflicting messages
right they're now gonna give you a
spoiler warning here I'm going to talk
about the end of this movie if you don't
want the spoilers cover your ears when
you see this spoiler warning go away
spoilers are done there's just something
at the end of this movie I can't get
over and I just don't like it and I just
want to tell you how I think they could
have made it better and they're really
abrupt and sudden ending in this movie
will Smith and Jaden Smith they both
live Jaden Smith sees Will Smith Will
Smith stands up off the table and then
he salutes his kids then Jaden Smith
runs up they give each other a hug you
see a tear come out of Will Smith's I
all right I get it that just bothers me
the fact that Will Smith stands up in
his first reaction is to salute his kid
like a soldier just me that their
father-son bond you know the thing that
we're supposed to be rooting for through
this entire movie it hasn't been growing
at all it hasn't grown Will Smith
saluting Jaden Smith all that shows me
is that Will Smith respects him as a
soldier but that's it I thought we were
supposed to root for their father-son
bond I thought we were supposed to watch
that grow how about this scenario Will
Smith stands up runs over to Jaden Smith
gives him a hug they both embrace that
then Jaden Smith pulls away and then he
goes to salute his dad his dad grabs his
hand puts it down and then Will Smith
salutes Jaden Smith that shows that Will
Smith's first reaction was to be a
loving father not a soldier
which would be new which would be growth
and that he does respect
Smith as a soldier also the soldier
aspect is second the father aspect
that's first Family Values mom would be
proud there you go but now we're stuck
with the fact that Will Smith respects
Jaden Smith as a soldier and if you're
gonna say that embrace and tear out of
Will Smith's eye is his growth he can
argue that actions speak louder than
words the fact that he saluted him first
shows that he just views him as a
soldier that he'll tear things probably
something little Smith will just pass
off as a momentary weakness a lapse in
judgment that he will never allow to
happen again cuz he's a hard individual
oh this just bothered me I like a
good survival movie as much as the next
guy but in the end the only survival
scenario is how long I can actually sit
through this movie the more I talk about
it the more I just I don't like it I
like sci-fi I like survival movies I
liked Shyamalan at one point they should
have been gold or at least really good
silver no it's not in the end I'm gonna
say after earth is
I've rude for this guy for a while I
think I gotta throw in that towel right
after Earth have you seen it what's your
favorite sci-fi movie that's not you
know Star Trek or Star Wars something
else that's like Oh sci-fi that's a cool
one and sometimes I forget about that
one whatever it is comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you